well I would say that sexuality when I
was growing up in Ghana wasn't the form
of identity gay sexuality because there
just wasn't there wasn't the public
discourse there weren't words for for
this I went to an English boarding
school a boys school so I pretty quickly
acquired acquired the words and so I had
a sort of language for talking to myself
and maybe to some friends in England
about my the discovery the iron or
sexual orientation was my own sexual
desires were directed towards my own sex
and not towards women
but but that wasn't something that I
mean if I'd sort of as it were worn a
t-shirt saying I was gay when I was 15
in Ghana people would have had no idea
what I was talking about that's changed
I mean there is now there are now gay
organizations and gay movements in Ghana
and while the government hasn't on the
whole moved in a bad direction in
response to that I would say there isn't
a huge sort of social consensus on the
badness of former sexuality there's
still just a lot of people haven't
thought about it very much and so they
will take a view if you give them a view
if you give them leave and Jellicle view
they'll take that but it's not because
they're deeply committed to it my father
is famous in my family that when my
father was asked about this he said he
said well I can see why you would have
sex with a man because sex is
pleasurable what I can't see is why you
wouldn't want to have sex with women so
again this is a different way this is a
different set of cultural context for
thinking about sexuality for for many
people in Ghana today I think gay men
are men who don't want to have sex as
women it's not what they do want to do
that's interesting about them it's what
they don't want to do though there is a
significant evangelical Christian
influence from the United States in
particular that's pushing a more
american-style form of what I regard as
homophobia as far as my own son dealing
with these things was concerned
I was raised in a you know in a
Christian family that we went to Sunday
school it wasn't the kind of Sunday
school that talked much about the I
don't think anyone ever mentioned
homosexuality or gayness
in church was like so far as I can
recall the whole time during my child
this wasn't one of the things that
people were preoccupied with my my
mother was British and my and then one
of my sisters godparents was a gay man
so I assumed she and you know obvious to
me when I was 8 that he was gay so even
though I didn't really have a very
well-developed sense of what that was so
I assumed that my parents didn't think
that that was an obstacle but my own
dealing with it really came from the
kind of Protestantism evangelical but in
that in this case I would say
progressive with evangelical
Protestantism which meant that you took
the key thought of the Gospels to be
that God loved us and it seemed to me as
I was working at my sort of own in
relationship to my sexuality that if if
I was like this and God loved me you
know the church might not think it was
okay but it couldn't be the case that
God didn't so I actually didn't have too
hard a time with this and I think I was
reconciled to my sexuality before as a
Christian before I eventually stopped
being a Christian but but i but this so
this is a sort of lucky story turned out
well I think that for people of my
generation in gonner men and women who
were who discover as they grow up that
they have sexual desires for their own
sex it was it was would have been
difficult and many of them would have
left I mean this I think a million gun
hands outside garner a moment in
Amsterdam and New York and London and
Manchester and cities like that around
Frankfurt cities around Europe and the
United States and you know I suspect
that a good number of them are gay
people who fled to their cities in the
way rural gay Americans
fly to cities because in cities you can
find other gay people and also perhaps
more tolerance of gay people but I think
Ghana will figure this out people in
Ghana like sex too much to think that
the hidden and the disappeared thing so
my hope is that things will move in the
right direction
I think reconciling different dimensions
of identity is actually something that
people are quite good at people know how
to be gay Mormons they that is I mean
the Mormon Church isn't so happy that
they now had a big a Mormons and maybe
some gay people don't like the fact that
they're gay Mormons but gay Mormons do
how to be gay Mormons and they know how
to be gay Mormon men they had a
reconciled agenda their sexuality and
their religion my father knew how to be
a Methodist began an app an Africa
missed a loyal son of the kingdom of a
shanty a father and you know all of
those things were things that could
follow you in certain moments in
different directions being a loyal
Ghanaian meant he had to go to
Parliament and leave the family and not
spend as much time with us when we were
growing up as he might of being a
supporter being in cosmopolitan
supportive United Nations meant that
sometimes he had to support he had to be
on the side of governments that were
opposed to our own government because
there are international norms that our
own government wasn't respecting and so
on so you know people have complex
identities but it's one of the things
human beings know how to handle it's
usually other people that makes it
difficult for you it's the homophobes
who make it difficult for the gay
Mormons or the ante Mormons who make it
difficult for the gay Mormons and while
I don't want to underestimate the
struggling that goes on in the process
of dealing with one's religious identity
or one's sexual orientation as one grows
up these are at least could be these are
challenging difficulties for young
people usually the big problems are
derived from either what other people do
think of what they think other people
will think and which brings us back to
our to our main topic because because at
the heart of this is a concern to be
respected and to be entitled to respect
and to be respected as what one is to be
respected not in spite of being a gay
person or in spite of being a Mormon or
in spite of being a Catholic or Jew but
as a Catholic or a Jew or a moment or a
gay person and one of the thing
we need to figure out in many of our
honor codes is to make them more
friendly to all kinds of people who are
currently excluded by them and that's
that's the task I think not abandoning
honor but reshaping it to make it
supportive of human flourishing both by
using collective honor to get people to
engage in the moral revolutions that are
necessary and by using individual honor
to sustain excellence in human lives